it is a pleasure to see you again
yes it's been 11 years
you were one of the first people i ever
interviewed i remember
i got this big new job on television i
had to interview you
and a bunch of your cast mates but he's
just not that into you which is still
one of my favorite movies
and the first actress i interviewed was
so mean to me that i wanted to quit my
job
straight away and then the next room i
walked into was yours
the second i walked into the room you
just looked me up and down you were
dressed like marilyn monroe
and you looked so incredible and you
just said well aren't you just a tall
drink of water and so i feel as though
you were flirting with me but it really
worked
and i uh and i sat down and you were so
kind
and so generous and understanding and
reminded me
that class and royalty still exists
in hollywood and you just reminded me
that people don't have to be
a bench just because they're really
successful
that is a new term i'd like to
incorporate a bench i just
love that um can you explain
like what the misery index game is i'd
much rather hear it from you than a fan
girl like me
okay so you have the scale of 1 to 100
of misery 100 being the most misery and
you have all of these unfortunate events
and all you have to do is decide
where each of these events lands on the
misery index in order to win
thirty thousand dollars and it's just
basically how much empathy you have it's
a game show about empathy putting
yourself in other people's shoes
uh for money i also love that they bring
these like
amazing cardboard cutouts of you around
the show and
um jamila you have these amazing long
legs and you rock these like
pant suits and why do you like wearing
pant suits may i ask hey i love
androgyny b
i love the fact that they're practical
you know so
200 years ago someone just decided that
men should wear
trouser suits because they're easy to
put on and easy to get around in and
women should wear
corsets and petticoats and big frills
and long dresses
so that it's as inconvenient as possible
for us to get ready and i love
i find them really sexy i love the fact
that i can sit with my legs
wide open i love a good man's spread
what's not to love but um you also in
the fashion world have a really
fantastic
collaboration announcement will you tell
us about that today
i am working with tommy hilfiger on this
new
much more sustainable campaign called
moving forward together with a bunch of
incredible activists from all around the
world and
amongst them is india moore who is an
incredible actress and
trans activist and so i'm super proud to
partner with them
i agree and i really get excited about
who
is gonna do a collab with them and it
just
feels like it's about more than fashion
and yet the clothes are always like you
want the clothes
i love that so much now your podcast i
way started as a social media post and
now it has over
1.3 million followers on instagram
and a youtube channel and a podcast
where you have
spoken to the likes of reese witherspoon
and other extraordinary female voices
that we hang on their every
word what is iway's mission so iway is a
movement against shame and it's a
movement of radical inclusivity it
started with a post of the kardashians
where i saw numbers written across all
their bodies and i
presumed it must be how much money
they've earned or how many awards
they've won and it was actually just how
much they weigh and i just thought
wow you would never see a picture of
businessmen
with their weight written across their
bodies because we don't care about how
much men weigh we only care however
about what women weigh
so i decided to one day post what i
weigh which is my financial independence
my relationship
my friendships my activism the things
that i'm struggling with still
the things that i've overcome i weigh
the sum of all of my parts
but i uh i i posted it and 10
000 people or so posted theirs back to
me within three days so i started an
instagram account i thought it was just
going to be a passing phase
and now this month we hit three years
and we have we're going over almost
we're on our way to 1.5 million
followers
we have a podcast amazing youtube
channel and
we are you know working on three bills i
just spoke in congress
uh i'm hoping to take it to the supreme
court uh in order to
you know help around eating disorders in
schools and weight discrimination in
schools
and we've changed global policies at
facebook and instagram
i love the mission i love the movement i
love the diversity of what you're
putting out into the world
now it's meat week on the show do you
have a favorite
meat dish i do it's not good for you
but it's called a scotch egg and it's a
boiled egg
surrounded in ground questionable pork
and then it's deep fried in breadcrumbs
and it is glorious
well i'm about to experience my first
scotch egg so
thank you camila hold on a minute i'm
curious about how this is gonna go
oh that's delicious oh my god oh my god
it shouldn't work but it does camila
jamil
you are everything and the misery index
airs tuesdays
at 10 30 9 30 central on tbs
and check out jamila and tommy
hilfiger's spring 2021 campaign
the collection is available now and also
tune into
iway wherever you listen to podcasts
jamila jamil thank you
and for teaching me about the scotch egg
this is so
good i'm glad you like it
[Music]